NARRATOR: When you look at
this picture, what do you see?
A disoriented seahorse, a
ghost woman, a boomerang.
This is actually Massachusetts'
7th Congressional District.
And these are some
other creatures--
I mean districts.
[music playing]
Congressional districts
are geographic voting
areas represented by a
single member of Congress.
[music playing]
Gerrymandering happens when
a political party in charge
carefully slices up
voting districts,
so that the representatives
they want to win-- win.
[cheers]
They do this by
drawing the districts
around the populations most
likely to support them,
or splitting up populations
less likely to support them,
making this outline
of a stegosaurus.
The practice is named for
Massachusetts' politician
and founding father,
you've likely
never heard of, Elbridge Gerry.
[music - "yankee doodle"]
Yes, it's pronounced GAR-ee.
Elected to the Continental
Congress in 1775,
Gerry signed the
Declaration of Independence.
He was also very involved
in shaping the Constitution,
but he didn't sign that.
Because as an anti-federalist,
he opposed a stronger
federal government, believing
the Constitution got
the balance of power all wrong.
Gerry thought the
federal government
had way too much of it.
Gerry eventually joined the
Democratic Republican Party.
Yes, that was a real thing.
In 1810, at age 65,
Gerry was elected
Governor of Massachusetts.
Around this time, the
United States was edging
toward war with Great Britain.
Concerned that Federalist
might betray the country,
Gerry's party decided
to find ways to replace
every possible
Federalist in office
with a Democratic Republican.
This included changing
Massachusetts' Senate districts
from reflecting county
lines to ones benefiting
the Democratic Republicans.
In the grand tradition
of political satire,
an Illustrator drew a picture
of one of Gerry's new districts,
depicting it as a
monster that supposedly
looked like a salamander--
no, a gerrymander.
The drawing ran in the Boston
Gazette on March 26, 1812.
From that year
onward, Elbridge Gerry
would be known, not for
signing the Declaration
of Independence, or helping
to frame the Constitution,
or for being the fifth Vice
President of the United States.
Yeah, he did that too.
Gerry would instead be known for
the controversial redistricting
practice that bears his
name, even though we now
pronounce it, gerrymandering.
[music playing]